je sais que je suis une femme bien sûr
je sais pas ce que je sais quand je suis
devenue une femme moi moi je sais
précisément quand je suis devenue une
femme s'érode
moi je suis devenue une femme le jour où
j'ai couché avec un homme marié
c'est là que je suis une femme non c'est
vrai parce qu'on a coutume de dire qu'on
devient une femme quand on a ses règles
moi non je le jour j'ai eu mes règles
j'ai surtout pris conscience que j'étais
complètement dépressif sauvé parce qu'on
m'avait dit tu vas voir on est triste un
peu avant les règles et pendant les
règles c'est moi ça ne change rien du
tout donc je voire même je suis plus gai
pendant des règles moi de là je les hais
les jeunes faisaient